[Music]
movie and TV actors will soon join
Hollywood writers on the picket lines
bringing all new and ongoing production
to a screeching halt it's the first
double whammy entertainment strike in 63
years what was historic about it is that
we were
really so
marginalized so Dishonored and so
respect disrespected
that it was
really egregious
and disgusting
here's a glimpse of the Brave New World
driving movie and TV actors to go on
strike the new Indiana Jones movie with
81 year old actor Harrison Ford's face
rearranged by artificial intelligence
tools to look as if he's in his mid-30s
the actors are concerned that their
images and likenesses will be used
without their permission and most
importantly without them being paid
AI along with concerns about wages
residual payments and other changes in
the entertainment industry is seen by
actors as an existential threat Union
president Fran Drescher told Al Jazeera
we don't want to be replaced by digital
images of ourselves and we don't want
big business to think it's okay to think
that that is a viable consideration just
because you can doesn't mean you should
the movie and TV producers Association
says it was disappointed and that they
had offered the actors a fair deal
Disney CEO Bob Iger who reportedly makes
upward of 45 million dollars a year
bemoan the strikes knock-on effects
there's huge collateral damage in the
industry to people who are you know who
are Support Services I could go on and
on
as the strike goes into effect
Productions worldwide will stop abruptly
when the actors are on strike movie
making and TV making grinds to a halt so
what does this all mean for the audience
consumers of entertainment in movie
theaters far fewer new theatrical
releases and on television screens
likely more sporting events and
unscripted reality series and of course
plenty more reruns Rob Reynolds Al
Jazeera Los Angeles